Kate Hudson poses totally naked on  social media kate is completely  confident in her own skin the 37 year  old actress shared an epic flashback  photo on Instagram in honor of throwback  Thursday that has the Internet going  nuts it's an ode to all kinds of tissues  here the almost famous star is seen  putting her toned body on full display  Kate bared her butt while standing in  front of a window next to a sign that  spells love the mom of two chatted with  et back in October at the grand opening  of her phonetics boutique and she says  she owes her outlook on body confidence  to her mother Goldie Hawn think that's  kind of her beauty and confidence really  comes from that's my mom's whole thing